[Music]
i'd like to start by thanking uh
daniela and samantha and phil for
organizing
this session i am very excited
to talk to you about um their validation
hub
and the work that uh we have been doing
to
aid you in the process of using our in a
regulatory setting
and of course let you know how you can
contribute
um so this is a quick overview of my
talk i'm gonna start by
um telling you what is our validation
hub
um i'll go quickly um through the white
paper
which talks about uh
an approach to assess the accuracy of
our packages within a validated
infrastructure
and um following this white paper and
using this philosophy
i'm going to introduce you to two of the
tools that we have
we have been working on on our package
called risk metric
and the risk assessment um china
application
and at the end i'll provide you with
further resources uh
where you can obtain more information
and how you can be part of the art
validation hub
and of course a disclaimer debuts
thoughts and opinions expressed in this
presentation belong
solely to me and i'm not necessarily
my employers or organizations or
committee uh
bees or thoughts um so a little bit
about me
oh excuse me this is a very out of the
picture it looks
more like this now so i am a pure
mathematician and a data scientist
i work as an intern for r studio um
with maxcon in the title models team i
enjoy anything r i have taken the
certification for
chinese and thai diverse and i'm still
waiting for greg
to put out more trainings so i can have
fun
taking them i currently work at biogene
in an awesome team led by bob ingle
and i'm also part of the executive
committee of their validation hub
which now has eight members
the chair of the our validation hub is
andy nichols
from the ask we have members from merck
biogene gen tech r studio faster
and their validation hub was formed in
2018
and is part of the art consortium
working group
we have around 100 members from multiple
or multiple organizations
across the pharmaceutical sector as you
can see
in the work cloud on the right uh our
members um
are johnson johnson fda and jen
ellie lillian and about 100 total
members
now the art validation hub is a cross
industry initiative to enable the use of
art by the pharmaceutical industry in a
regulatory setting
where the output may be used in
submissions
to regulatory agencies now to support
our mission
we wrote a white paper titled
every space approach for assessing our
package accuracy within a valid
invalidated infrastructure this paper
was written by
anthony nicole from the sk paolo barco
from
johnson and john simms from pfizer
and um in this theme of this paper is to
um
propose a possible risk-based approach
for assessing our package
accuracy within a validated
infrastructure
these white paper addresses concerns
erased by statistician programmers
quality assurance teams and others
within the pharmaceutical industry
about the use of r and selected our
packages
as a primary tool for a statistical
analysis for regulatory and submission
work
uh now the white paper is based um
or rather the definition that we use of
validation in the white paper
is based on the fda definition of
validation
which you can read more about in the
linked article and
and their validation can be separated in
three and main components
accuracy reproducibility and
traceability
and uh the white paper we focus on
accuracy we focus on the on this uh
quality uh
qualitative assessment of correctness or
freedom from error
and on the white paper we propose a
risk-based approach to establish
accuracy of those packages that are
contributed packages
and so we make a decision between
core versus contributed our packages
and core packages we say there are those
packages
that are part of the official art
distribution
as formally released by their foundation
so
these software is commonly referred to
as base r plus recommended packages
now these packages are considered to be
a low risk
and um we made this this determination
based
on how their foundation develops their
language
you can read more on about
how their foundation describes
um and how their foundation
takes their approach to developing their
language uh their testing
approach and how they release versions
in the link document
and we can by reading this document you
um
may agree with us that the arcore team
controls
are like any of the companies that
produces
uh the commercial software that you may
buy in this space
so they are packages are the core our
patches are very well controlled
and so uh can be considered to be low
risk
now the complement we have um those
packages
um that are contributed that i met that
are made by the community
which are about 70 000 packages now on
cran and
the risk of these packages really
depends on
various factors uh like how will the
package develop
uh is it well tested the packages may
have
varying software development life cycles
that you should be aware and
you also can check for how much exposure
has the package had within the user
community
and in the white paper we propose as i
mentioned an approach to assess the
accuracy
of the contributed packages as those
core
are considered to be low risk so
once someone in your company wants to
use one of these contributed packages
the question is what steps can you take
to start to assess the risk of those
packages so the white paper can be you
um in taking the first steps to start
assessing
the risk of using another package
so once um do you have decide that you
want to use
a package uh the next step
that we propose uh for you to do is to
access the package based on four
criteria
purpose maintenance good practice
community usage and testing
and so when talking about purpose
it is assumed that any package that
we're talking about is
intended to be used within a exp
workflow so package directly
manipulating data
creating graphics or running a running a
statistical model
that forms part of destination we're
referring to those
so in terms of risk
any package should be weighted equally
but we do recognize that modeling
statistical packages
deserve special attention and we know
that there is an innate difficulty
to identify errors in those packages um
in those modeling packages versus those
say
on the manipulate data so for instance
if you would like to test the arrange
function of the plier
it is easy to do you can or relatively
easy to do you can use a small data set
to test this function and check that the
corresponding column has been
sorted correctly on the other hand
statistical models are harder to test
and a statistician can roughly check
that a model is correct
but not correct to the decimal places
now in terms of maintenance good
practice um it's good to
um to address the questions on how is
the documentation of the package
is the source code public on github or
any other medium
and um we we do know that when you
when you expose a package to the
community you helps reduce the risk
as uh even if the package has no tasks
but it's popular you know that it has
been widely used
by the community and so lastly uh
testing
um is a crucial part of the
sdlc and another uh
maintenance best practice metric
in general the white paper proposes this
workflow
uh which you are encouraged to read more
um in our website which i'm gonna
provide a link to
at the end of the presentation now
before
showing you the um the apk that we have
been working on
i want to point out um a misconception
we're talking about
uh open source uh software like r uh
it's important to know that
no statistical software can purchase as
pre-validated software
in this regulatory context so what
happens is that validation is up to the
user
to implement so for instance sas is not
a pre-validated software
however given the dominance of some of
the solvers um
in the industry many companies
have collected evidence through a long
period of time
that details the testing and validation
of
functions procedures etc and so
when you use this software
um rather than reinventing the wheel and
duplicating testing which has already
been performed in the past by others
uh we make the decision to use um
that software based on its history of
extensive previous use
as we decide to do with sas procedures
for instance so
following this philosophy um you can see
our packages uh as having received
validation
through a variety of sources validation
by the arena authors of the package
by users of the packaging academia
by users in a wide variety of industries
like google amazon microsoft um by
companies such as mango solutions and
even by the fda themselves who have been
using our internally now for some time
so in the same way that we can trust um
a long-standing uh sas package we can
start thinking
about our packages in the same way
so if we wanna if we believe this to be
the case then we need to
uh look at which packages we can add to
our safe list
to do that we have been working on the
risk metric art package
which follows the philosophy in the
white paper and tries to answer
uh questions like uh who who are the
authors
um how many time has the package been
downloaded
uh does the package um is the package
well tested what is it test coverage of
the package
is the source called public and on
service metric as i mentioned is on our
package
which measures the risk of using
our packages and this risk is calculated
based on a number of metrics that are
meant to evaluate
development best practices code
documentation
development sustainability and community
engagement
now it's important to note that this
risk the risk
tray various metric does not represent
the risk of damaging
the system in which the package is
installed
or the risk that the internal
statistical functions are correct
although indirectly the package does
checks
um that the statistical functions are
correct but by looking at the testing
on the community usage and the bug
reports and so on
so if you apply the risk metric r
package to g plot
um you will obtain a low risk so the
lowest risk the risk ranges from zero to
one
so you're gonna be in the lowest risk
one being the highest
the highest risk that you can get and
when you do plot
you obtain 0.2 so that is a low risk
and if you use a new package uh like
rules from the tidy models uh
which is a new package created this year
if i'm not mistaken
you will get a high risk uh and of
course getting a high risk will point
you to
directions in which you have to look
further in the package like do you have
to create tests do you have to provide
more documentation
but in general this doesn't mean that
you can't use the package
but rather that probably you have to
make more tests
and so let's take a look at the
functions in cyrus metric
or the main functions and as i mentioned
the package is on github
um in the link provider
feel free to contact us to contribute
we're always looking for people
to help out build this package
and so if the package is on on
on github as i mentioned i'm not on cran
yet
and so once you install the package
using dev tools
and you load it you can follow uh
our workflow which starts by
finding a source for package information
using the package
reference function and it will look for
packages install
locally installed or on gran or git
once you have applied the package
reference function
you can move on to assess so what that
will do is look at the different metrics
and
find information for at the different
metrics for
the metrics as vignettes and r news
currents and so on
and lastly you can apply the patches for
a function
which will score the package
based on the assessment criteria on
those metrics
so then the results will be assembled
in a in a data set um
that contains the overall risk and
the other metrics so as you can see
below you will see the output
of metrics for um to improve how it
looks let's use
cable extra and there you can see
um the different metrics so we have for
instance
so each column is uh information some
new information about the package and
the rows we have
particular packages so we have gta plot
and walls
you can see the version that we are
assessing
the risk as per trade by risk metric the
downloads on the score one year
uh which measures the percentage of um
of the number of downloads in the last
year um so you can see
how much has g block been downloaded
versus
uh rules and so on now um to
as you can see reading the metrics on
this table uh although we have used um
cable x-rays um may be hard to
understand
and um you can you cannot interact with
the race and with the packages
so to provide a better user interface to
deal with the risk we have been working
on a shiny application
uh called the risk assessment china
application uh which provides you a
framework
framework where you can interact with
the risk provide comments
you can create reports
and also you can in general
you can take advantage of using chinese
meaning that you don't need to code you
don't need to explicitly call those
functions on this metric
and you have an interactive way uh to
measure risk
so i'm gonna do something risky i'm
gonna try to show you how application
looks like
give a quick live demo the application
is on
github and feel free to reach out to us
to contribute
we have meetings weekly
and you can join us the link to do that
is on our website
um so let me try to switch um
to uh other window see how that goes
and let's see
okay
let's try that
okay um okay perfect so
once you load the application this is
how it looks like um
you can provide a user id and a role
uh when you click proceed to application
you can upload the package um
and the structure of the csv file
is as you can see here on the screen you
can download this uh
template and use it for the application
for the sake of time
i have uploaded uh three packages
so if we take a look at deep plier for
instance
you will see uh the same metrics that we
saw on
on the table uh portray here
but you will have more information into
what the matrix mean
and um instead of seeing 0.9 you will
see a percentage as you will expect that
too
um so it will tell you um does it happen
yet
uh is current um how many exported
objects there are
i will tell you uh the percentage of
book
closure does it had a maintainer
and so let me do this
when um you can also look at the number
of downloads
um in the last six months one year
and you can see that uh deploy is highly
popular
um and um so you can provide comments
on on the metrics and once you provide
comments and are happy
with how the metrics are portrayed or
the risk of the package
you can provide an overall risk a low
maybe on high
depending on your insertion of the
package and after you do that you can
download
a report containing all the metrics um
the number of downloads and your
comments on the package
so the application has other
functionalities
that you can play around with and again
the application is on github so you can
um uh you can feel free to do so
and so let me switch back to the
presentation
and okay
so let's see
why not use the right one
okay
okay let me see if i can do that
my screen
can you can you check with me that you
can see um
the screen yeah i so i don't see
anything yet here what if i try
refining you as presenter maybe
sure do something different um here let
me quickly try that
okay here we go and then
usually live demos don't go very well
so but it's good to give it a try i
wanted you to
to take a look at the application um
totally i appreciate your bravery
okay so let's see um okay i think you
can see it now
right yes that looks great now awesome
so that's application again feel free to
um
go to github and play around with
application provide feedback
or any new features um and so to find
out more about these tools
you can go to the farmer website where
you can see the blog posts presentations
um and the white paper also feel free to
join our mailing list
and um you can send a message message to
or
or the email provided on the slide to
contribute and also if you want to learn
more detail about the white paper and
these tools we did a workshop last year
on our pharma and um and there is a link
on the slides that
the slides will be shared later where
you have the video to the workshop
and um testing exercises that we did
during the workshop
and um i'd like to end by thanking the
evaluation hub
and the contributors of the risk magic
package
um doug dilon eric um
eli and i'm pretty sure i'm missing
uh some considerators and the
contributor service assessment um
package um the risk assessment excuse me
application
especially to robert um aaron and maya
who have been working with me on the
application and i'd like to
thanks to to our studio and prague for
organizing this pharma accession and
to all of you for coming to the station
thank you